well kevin groves is head of media
relations at network rail and he joins
us from london's houston station kevin
thank you so much for talking to us so
where are we with these talks
well the talks are ongoing uh they
started about eight o'clock
this morning and uh they've just had a
lunch break and we're expecting them to
resume uh later this afternoon so uh
whilst there's talks ongoing there's
still a sliver of hope that we can find
some way through this dispute and find a
compromise that works for everyone but i
have to say that sliver of hope as the
day progresses is getting ever smaller
and why is that what is that down to
well unfortunately even if there was a
breakthrough uh this afternoon and i
don't know whether that's going to
happen or not um the the timetable that
has been set in stone now we are beyond
the uh the point of no return for uh for
what passengers can expect from the
railway in terms of services for
tomorrow so uh the 20 service 50 of the
network closed um people need to check
before they travel and and uh really
should only use the train if they must
uh that is now what is going to happen
tomorrow even if white smoke does appear
and there's no indication um at this
point that that's going to be the case
okay and what would it take for that can
you hear me it's all right you just sort
out your earpiece it's okay
can you hear me let me know when you can
okay
so um in terms of the white smoke
what do you think would take for that to
happen
well that's a good question obviously
the the rnt have put their demands out
that they want a uh uh a a a large pay
rise or something near inflation and and
clearly um that's at the rate of
inflation at the moment that's that's
unaffordable the railway finances are in
to be frank a bit of a mess
they're saying it's not actually at the
rate of inflation your numbers are no
way
it's not actually at the rate passenger
numbers on on
the rate of inflation when talks started
which were back at the turn of the year
so that's something like seven eight
percent
um and that is clearly uh uh
unaffordable when the railway finances
are in such a such a mess we've only got
75 passengers back uh compared to where
we were in 2019 that creates about 2 000
million shortfall in in income
so that's the reality of railway
finances and it's our job to try and
find and negotiate with the rmt to to be
pragmatic and say look guys we need we
need a deal that gives a fair rise um a
fair pay rise to our colleagues and
employees but also it's something that
taxpayers and fair players can afford
and it's trying to find that middle
ground
which is why uh talks are continuing um
there is some progress uh small steps um
but uh but uh the slither of hope of a
resolution is not great what would be um
a pay rise that you would accept then if
it's not the 7.1 percent that's what
inflation was back in december which
mike lynch says that's when the deal
should have been
made so if 7.1
isn't acceptable for you then what is
well
i'd love to sit down and discuss the
negotiating strategy of of of network
rail and the in the trade unions but uh
i'm not sure that's that's helpful for
the guys in the in the room who'll be
getting back around the table in in
about an hour's time so let's let's
leave that for them but as far as
listeners and viewers are concerned they
need to know that whether we find a way
through this and find a compromise that
works for everyone or not
passenger train services tomorrow will
be severely affected and people
shouldn't try and travel by train
tomorrow unless they must
and if they do want to travel please
check before you travel on websites to
see what trains are running and what
trains aren't trains will only start
running from about half seven in the
morning and they'll be finished by half
past six in the evening so there will be
a very early close down to services
tomorrow morning tomorrow evening
just finally would it be easier if the
government were involved do you think it
is time for them to step in now
the government has given us a very clear
mandate and framework to work from and
indeed
we think
that what they've given us and the
ability to if the union would compromise
on the modernizing um the working
practices that the crown just referred
to in the earlier interview gives us
enough wiggle room and flexibility to
deliver savings that we can pass on to
to our colleagues but at the moment
there's a bit of an impasse on how
willing they are to move
it's a bit more take than give on the
negotiating table at the moment we just
need a bit more wiggle room and
compromise to find our way through
okay kevin thank you so much for talking
to us
my pleasure